hey this is Danielle rose Russell I'm
here today at BuzzFeed taking the witch
Vampire Diaries character ru quiz first
how would you describe me how would your
friends describe you brave generous
charming loyal hard-working intelligent
I guess hard working working so do I
pick it yeah I pick it I'm taking the
quiz this is like from my bedroom at
home this is like amazing
thank your favorite school subject
history English math art science foreign
language definitely not math definitely
not science No Shave just not my thing
and I suck at art not a foreign language
I guess either history or English but
I'm gonna lean more towards English
English choose a famous vampire Edward :
from Twilight Rebekah Mikaelson from The
Vampire Diaries
Dracula spike from Buffy the Vampire
Slayer Selene from underworld
Bill Compton from True Blood I think I'm
gonna have to go classic here Dracula
it's where it all began right which
supernatural creature would you rather
be vampire werewolf which hybrid tribrid
double ganger I feel obligated to say
tribrid because you're all three and you
get all three abilities which is kind of
cool but if I wasn't gonna pick tribe
red I think I would say vampire that's
my favorite supernatural but I'm gonna
pick I would pick a character to team up
with Tyler Lockwood Elijah Mikaelson
Josie Saltzman Liz Forbes Hayley
Marshall hope Michaelson can't team up
with myself so I feel like hope and
Elijah would be like a real dynamic duo
which we got to see a little bit of in
the originals if you're a true fan so
when I say Elijah they feel like they'd
like really if hope like went full dark
try Brett and Elijah like when he's a
crazy rip herself iconic choose a
monster to fight dragon gargoyle neck
answer banshee zombie malla 4 I think
I'm gonna have to sing necromancer he's
a really cool character I think we're
really cool and I want to see him back
at her show finally pick something
important from the Vampire Diaries
universe a daylight ring Elena's diary
Mystic Falls Founders Day celebration
vervain Salvatore boarding house The
Cure I think I'd have to say the
Salvatore boarding house because in
otherwise our characters like we didn't
have a school and it wouldn't be a show
so stopped recording house Thank You
Salvatore brothers hey I got Stefan
Salvatore your personality matches
Stefan their courageous determined and
brave wow I don't know how you guys to
turn all that from my answers like stuff
and you will do whatever it takes to
protect the people you love even if it
means sacrificing your own happiness
you're a hopeless romantic I'd have to
say yes do those things
the world isn't now but it doesn't help
us romantics Oh alright I guess I can
kind of say it's nothing I'm down for
that
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure you guys watch legacies Thursday at
9:00 8:00 central on the CW
bye guys best feed places like took up
my childhood like come on
BuzzFeed quizzes are like the most
important staple in the Internet are you
kidding me